thanks for being with us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show we're glad you're
here
[Music]
you know it's interesting and
informative to all of us to stop and
think about something
hope causes you to be able to move the
needle causes you to be able to move
forward when you think the light at the
end of the turn at the end of the tunnel
is an oncoming train you're paralyzed
you're stopped you're overwhelmed you're
frozen you get paralysis or the analysis
that's hopelessness when you think of
the light then the tunnel is the way out
of your trap then you run to the light
but if the Train is coming at you and
run to that obviously right and what's
the difference in those two events both
light both the tunnel both the situation
one is you believe that if you run to
the light you're going to get out one of
you believe you've run to the light
you're going to get killed right I mean
so that's hope and hopelessness and all
of us me included face that or have
faced that at times in our lives and
it's amazing to me the power of our
brain and our spirit that God gives us
to do things that are way beyond what we
thought we could do once we believe that
they're possible
that's called hope and so when I show
you look you know you make $100,000 a
year
you got $30,000 in debt you feel stuck
but gosh if we did that at $1,000 a
month you're gonna be out of debt and my
gosh and $1,000 a month out of a hundred
thousand it's nothing that's twelve
thousand dollars a year you're gonna be
out of debt in a little over two years
and you suddenly go oh I see it ding
ding it's the same situation you were in
but now you can see it you see what I'm
talking about and once you can see it
that's called hope I can see my way out
one of the things that steals your hope
is when you have lost your perspective
the perspective is of course your point
of view the way you're seeing things
it's happened to me it's happened to you
I remember one time one of my daughters
when she was in high school a certain
boy did not call at a certain time that
he was supposed to call and
she was very upset like the world is
coming to an end and her mom and I are
trying to quit laughing so we can walk
in and comfort her now why are we
standing in the hall outside her bedroom
laughing and why is she in there
hopeless well we've got perspective we
see things that she doesn't see because
we've been in places she hasn't been and
have experiences that she doesn't have
right so in other words we've been to
our 20 year class reunion we know she'll
be glad he didn't call that's what we're
giggling about standing in the hall
right so we have perspective and so we
you know when you don't have respect
when you cannot see the other side
you're standing in poop up to your knees
but you can't see the other side of it
then you know it's not fertilizer at
that point it's just poop but when you
can see the other side of it then it's
fertilizer and it's gonna grow some
things in your future you know when
you're walking through garbage in other
words you're going to either there's
some good is gonna come out of the
garbage that you're in but but when it
gets right down on you and your vision
is just the end of your nose and not the
end of your life when you look out ten
years you see stuff different then when
you look out ten seconds and the young
man I was talking to and folks that I've
dealt with in homeless situations it's
one of the problem is the the
desperation just to eat and not be cold
causes you to have ten second increments
of thought instead of ten year
increments of thought see I can stand
back from that sitting here warm and
with a full belly in my studio several
thousand miles away and look at him and
go dude just go work more but he can't
see he couldn't see that you know y'all
can hear that you wasn't getting it it's
like Coco deliver pizzas go blow leaves
go walk dogs go shovel something
somewhere you know go do something go
you know work all the time because as
soon as you do that money comes from
work as where it comes from
I can't get enough hours well then work
someplace else work more work all the
time but because I've done that kind of
stuff and I'm the other side of it and
I've seen what it does mean I don't we
were going broke I had two little babies
and wife the house is in foreclosure
we're that close to homeless ourselves
so how we get out of it work their butt
off and well you can't work your way out
everything I didn't work my way out I
went bankrupt but I didn't lose the
house and if I hadn't lost the house I'd
have found some place to live and I'd
work my way into though an apartment and
we lived in that well you know and it's
not that I'm better it's not that I'm
smarter only thing is just perspective
it's like I didn't grow up bridge well I
had a friend that grew up rich and
because he grew up in a wealthy home he
had the perception that everything was
gonna work out because it had always
worked out and I had the perspective
that ain't gonna work out it's gonna be
awful and but because he thought
everything was gone was gonna work out
you know I worked out a lot because I
didn't think it was gonna work out
sometimes it didn't work out you said
you set yourself in these tracks and
these ruts with this thing but when you
can see the other side of it
it's easy to work through it it's when
you can't see the other side of it that
you don't want to work through it
because you don't believe it's gonna
work that's called hopelessness the
situation is exactly the same the only
different issue is your perspective and
so I'm challenging some of you right now
to think you're stuck you think you're
stuck in a career you think you're stuck
in this marriage that's bad it's always
going to be that way you think you're
stuck with whatever behavior you're
stuck with you think you're stuck with
your money you think you're stuck in
debt you're not stuck you're not stuck
life is not a snapshot it's a film strip
you're going to turn the page and
something else is going to happen better
or worse tomorrow
it is not gonna stay the same you are
not stuck so look the other side of it
look out there five years look out there
three years look out there ten months
say what have I got to do what's got to
be true that's not true right now for me
to never be here again that's the
question he was asking but he was having
trouble emotionally buying it
and I don't think I helped him it's kind
of bothered me that's why I want to talk
about it a minute I'm not sure he heard
me but if I woke up in his shoes
tomorrow if you took my wallet away with
what everything I have been through I
had no identity no I and you know my
driver's license was gone I didn't have
a car and you just dumped me on the
street I wouldn't be there long because
they don't believe that about me in my
future and I know if I do this this and
this that I'll be out and I would work
my way right out of it I don't know how
long to take but I would get there I
push my way through it and and I haven't
always been that way there's been times
that I was so scared and so beat-up and
so hopeless that I couldn't breathe and
I couldn't see what I'm talking about
here is vision sight that gives you hope
when you lose your sight when you can't
see the other side of it then there's no
you know that it's hard to take action
it's hard to fix it and the problem is
there's not a magic wand if there is a
series of things you've got to do a
series of steps you got to take to
become unstuck wherever it is you are
stuck wherever it is I'm stuck I think
that guy's gonna be okay
I really do I think he's gonna be better
off than he thinks he's gonna be I think
it's gonna work out great book to read
if you want reading called pizza tiger
the guy that started Domino's Pizza
Monaghan came out of the army made some
bad mistakes and ended up living in a
homeless shelter
then the ends up owning Domino's Pizza
at the end of story so it's gonna be
alright you know it can be you can
choose for it to be alright and it's not
magic and it's not positive thinking and
it's not easy it's hard but it's
perception and it's well the reasons i
read biographies of successful people is
it lets me know that they went through
crap and they made it and then if I'm
going through crap I'm going to make it
and that that's what I'm you know that's
where you are that's where I have been
and am sometimes it's gonna be okay it's
gonna turn out okay this is the Dave
Ramsey show